نظم العشرات من العاملين في المرافق
والمراكز الصحيه في محافظه الحديده ومدينه
الخوخه وقفه احتجاجيه اعتراضا على تخفيض
رواتبهم الى قلبنا النصف وكذا المحتجون
استمرار اضرابهم عن العمل حتى الاستجابه
لمطالبهم وسط مخاوف من حدوث كارثه انسانيه
بسبب الاضراب خرجنا من
اجل الغاء قرار تخفيض رواتبنا اكثر من 50%
واعاده الراتب او الحافز
الذي استمرينا منذ اربع سنوات حيث ان
الحافز الجديد
لا يكفي لمده عشر ايام وذلك بسبب التقاء
الغاء غلاء المعيشه والظروف الصعبه التي
تمر بها البلاد
[موسيقى]
تمرن المراكز في التغليف
كيف الاوبئه الاوبئه منشوره في الخوخه معك
الملاريا معك التايفي التيفود معك
منشوره طيب لما نتقفل المركز الصحي المريض
يتلقى الخدمه لا يخفى لدى الجميع انه اذا
تم انسحاب الكوادر الصحيه من القطاع الصحي
سوف يسبب كارثه انسانيه كبيره
لذا نناشد كل القائمين وصلنا القرار بان
ينظر الينا بعين الانسانيه
ويجدوا لنا الحل منصف حيث نحن لا نتقاضى
سوى رواتب ضئيله جدا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات